you're wrangling a circus that has to
over a course of a hundred days over
those hundred plus days you need
everybody to Peak
depending on what you need from them
what side of the room you're on what
you're looking at you need everybody to
peek at the same time everybody be in
the same movie everybody to be in the
same moment your sculpting Behavior over
time
and you're given a very very finite
amount of patience that the audience has
for you to get those ideas across it's
not Chinese checkers no it's it's
three-dimensional chess I don't want
your best version of this scene to
mandate how the scene gets cut I want
the best version of the story to mandate
where I am at any point in the room if I
have 15 setups you're gonna have to be
good 50 at least 15 times